I want to go in more to some of those
story ideas as well but I just want to
play a hypothetical let's say that you
and your colleagues are here on one side
of the table and I'm a screenwriter so
what is this initial meeting like what
should I be bringing with me what sure
what type of work should I have done
ahead of time and even really how should
I be dressed to come to this meeting I
think a screenwriter should look at a
pitch meeting as just a first date it's
uh it's not you don't have to come in
with every you don't want to come off
with static one-liners about what your
scripts are you want the conversation to
be organic you need to come in
professional you don't you have to dress
professional and that can just be casual
smart you know that you would be in a
bar and an evening or something like
that you know not not a sports bar but
someplace decent so you know casual
clothing and just just keep the demeanor
light and easy going you want the ideas
to feel free flowing you want them to
feel organic always have a cheat sheet
with you but in truth I mean just just
treat it like a first date like just let
the conversation of all you want to be
very receptive to other people's ideas
but really a pitch meeting is about
auditioning you as a writer to see if
you mesh well with the company are your
ideas and alignment if they're bringing
suggestions about changing the lead from
a male to a female are you comfortable
with that because those are the sorts of
situations that if you're under contract
and getting paid you'll have to listen
to and deal with and so they want to
make sure you're comfortable with that
and that you're ensinar G together so
keeping that hypothetical meeting going
what are some red flags that I should be
aware of that I should be careful of
certain phrases that I should say or
maybe even body posture I mean something
that's going to make me seem like I'm
not agreeable I I was the best way to do
it best way for me to fake confidence we
all have to fake confidence from time to
time is you know always expect the best
you know they have no preconceived
notions about who you are as a writer
and vice versa so don't always assume
that Hollywood is out to rip
new writers to take advantage we
actually we love our writers and scripts
are the foundation of great films and we
need them so we we are looking for the
next great writer we are looking to find
people we can mesh well with the best
way to come into a room be on time look
professional speak professionally and
when the decision maker in the room or
whomever orchestrated the meeting jumps
in with an idea stop and listen to them
and if an idea is presented that you
don't agree with don't attack it leave
it on the table don't don't counter it
right away you know just let the
conversation kind of evolved I think you
should always go into a pitch meeting
prepared with at least five to ten
fleshed out ideas you can keep that on a
cheat sheet of paper if you like and you
don't have to necessarily have all those
memorized and ready to roll you don't
even have to bring them up but if the
conversation moves into a direction of
what else do you have maybe the first
two scripts that got you the meeting
aren't what they want they want to see
what else you have you're ready to roll
with that and if you're reading one of
the pitches if you're giving one of the
pitches and they quickly say that's not
really in our wheelhouse we're not
interested stop and move on to the next
one it's not personal they just they
want to find out if you can deliver what
they need so summing it up just keep it
light and flexible yeah keep it very
light and flexible first date mentality
you're just trying to see if you mesh
well together do you communicate well
alright are you having fun I mean you
know don't you don't have to pull a
stand-up act or anything like that but I
mean you know make it make it light make
it easy it is not a terrifying
experience for them so it does not need
to be a terrifying experience for you ne
ne phrases a writer should definitely
not lie I'm just thinking of a job
interview no one wants to say oh well I
don't want to work overtime so something
is there something in the whole writers
sphere that's probably a red flag that
someone should hold their tongue on
I think the biggest thing a writer needs
to avoid is entitlement in truth it's
always be willing to make your script
flexible always be open and receptive to
new ideas and completely new takes on
your screenplay however ridiculous or
counter they may feel and and don't
treat your script like a baby even
though you've committed so much time and
energy into it it's just an object in
the eyes of everyone else and so you
have to be able to detach from it so
don't get too personal key phrases i'm
thoroughly any key phrases necessarily i
would avoid trying to say i know that
XYZ studio is into these projects right
now or that this is a popular trend
because in truth Hollywood's planning
movies out and series out two three
sometimes four years in advance so
they're not really playing the trend
game that's just something that kind of
happens organically as contents getting
out there so i wouldn't try to reference
that sort of stuff either
you